und damit noch einmal ganz herzlich
willkommen das ging für ihn ein bisschen
schneller als wir eigentlich gedacht
haben willkommen zu zdf heute live
soweit also die pressekonferenz nach der
heutigen bund länder runde mit unter
anderem natürlich den bundeskanzler olaf
scholz wir fassen kurz zusammen omikron
wird uns noch lange beschäftigen hat er
gesagt und wir werden noch viele
patienten haben muss dann sei nach wie
vor der beste schutz im januar sollen
wieder 30 millionen dosen verabreicht
werden insgesamt was das essen angeht
das tragen von masken nach wie vor ganz
zentral und wichtig die kontakte sollten
reduziert bleiben die einzelheiten was
kontakt beschränkungen und ähnliche
regelungen angeht wollen wir euch gleich
nochmal zeigen das machen wir nochmal in
grafischer form vielleicht noch kurz zu
den äußerungen auch von hendrik wüst dem
ministerpräsidenten aus
nordrhein-westfalen vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
alle länder bitten den bund zügig eine
allgemeine impfpflicht auf den weg zu
bringen es dürfe kein politisches
taktieren geben und die cdu geführten
länder und baden württemberg gemeinsam
fordern dass der bundestag die
epidemische lage feststellen soll in
franziska giffey hat sich auch geäußert
corinna politik muss maßvoll
unverhältnismäßig sein verwies dabei
unter anderem auch auf die beschlossenen
überbrückungshilfen 4 und zur
allgemeinen impfpflicht sagte sie der
gesetzgebungsprozess dürfe auf der
anderen seite aber auch nicht eben
überstürzt werden im februar nach einer
sondierungsphase im januar im februar
soll das dann auf den weg gebracht
werden also das bietet reichlich
gesprächsstoff und wir wollen darüber
sprechen mit zwei herrschaften die ich
jetzt vorstellen möchte zum einen mit
thorsten leer professor für klinische
pharmazie an der universität des
saarlandes einen schönen guten tag und
ganz herzlich willkommen genau er ist
rechts im bild beziehungsweise von euch
aus gesehen links und dann schauen wir
noch in das schöne bundesland
brandenburg und sprechen dort mit olaf
schöpe er ist dort präsident des
deutschen hotel und gaststättenverbandes
auch ihnen einen schönen tag und ganz
herzlich willkommen
so wir hören ihnen leider noch nicht ich
hoffe er kann uns aber es wirkte so wir
basteln gerade noch ein bisschen am ton
anfangen wir vielleicht mal mit herrn
lehmann herr lehrer sie haben ja gerade
die maßnahmen auch noch mal mitbekommen
die dort beschlossen worden sind
vielleicht mal ganz allgemein ihr
eindruck sind sie der meinung die
politik hat den schuss gehört sind die
massnahmen beschlossen worden sind
weitreichend genug aus ihrer sicht
ja ich glaube schon dass die politik
eigentlich den schuss gehört hat und
weiß dass da einer geschossen wurde aber
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sie wirklich
danach reagiert hat also erscheint es
mir zumindest ich denke die maßnahmen
wie ich jetzt hier sehen sind vielleicht
eine leichte verschärfung von dem was
wir bisher gesehen haben aber eigentlich
das radikale was ich hier erwartet hätte
beziehungsweise auch die auch den
ausblick etwas verschärft verschärfte
maßnahmen sehe ich wirklich nicht und
das ist ehrlich gesagt sehr enttäuschend
welcher punkt ist ihnen besonders
unangenehm aufgefallen was hätten sie
sich mehr erhofft
naja man muss ja schon sagen dass
bundeskanzler scholz auch schon
festgestellt hat dass die zahlen extrem
steigen werden wenn sie nach berlin
nicht nicht berlin oder auch bremen
schauen die nordischen länder dort haben
sie schon in bremen beispielsweise eine
verdreifachung der inzidenz jetzt auf
800 in den letzten zehn tagen hab da
sehen sie diese schon oft gesagt der
wand sehr massiv und ich glaube das
werden wir in allen bundesländern sehen
und jetzt irgendwie darauf zu hoffen
dass das nicht passieren wird uns
irgendwelchen gründen ist absolut
fahrlässig und ich glaube ich hier
bräuchten wir jetzt schon maßnahmen die
das eigentlich verhindern ich glaube die
politik möchte an der stelle einfach vor
allem erstmal nicht reagieren bzw wird
reagieren damit eben nicht agieren das
ist das große problem was ich hier sehe
sie wissen alle auf das was kommt denn
dass sie danach chef müssen aber ich
frage mich warum das heute noch nicht
beschlossen wurde ja vielleicht an
dieser stelle auch noch mal der ja
sozusagen immer während der aufruf an
euch liebes publikum und in der
gastronomie soll bald bund zum genau zu
diesem thema heute zu stellen jetzt
hatte ich gerade noch ein störgeräusch
auf dem ohr also gerne wieder her mit
euren fragen so weit schon mal der erste
aufschlag von thorsten leer aber es
macht durchaus sinn dass wir uns
vielleicht gerade noch mal genau die
beschlüsse von heute anschauen was ist
da genau eben besprochen und entschieden
worden in welche richtung geht das ganze
und dann können wir weiter darüber
inhaltlich diskutiert darin eine
zusammenfassung von meinem kollegen
benno krieger
so jetzt müsste da eine kleine
zusammenfassung komm ich hoffe es dauert
noch einen kleinen moment müsste dann
aber gleich losgehen
wenn es nicht losgehen in der
gastronomie soll bald bundesweit zweig
plus gelten also in restaurants bars und
kneipen das heißt geimpfte und genießen
dürfen gaststätten nur noch mit einem
tagesaktuellen test oder einer booster
impfung betreten auch soll es neue
quarantäne regeln geben
gepostete kontaktpersonen und menschen
die frisch geimpft oder genesen sind
müssen nicht in quarantäne
als frisch gift gelten personen bei
denen die zweite impfung mindestens 14
tage oder maximal zwei monate
zurückliegt
personen bei denen die zweite impfung
länger als zwei monate zurückliegt
müssen zehn tage in quarantäne
sie können sich allerdings nach sieben
tagen frei testen lassen
schüler können sich bereits nach fünf
tagen frei testen
bislang galt kontaktpersonen einer mit
der omicron variante infizierten
personen müssen 14 tage in quarantäne
frei testen konnten sie sich bisher
nicht neue regeln gibt es auch für
infizierte sie können sich jetzt nach
sieben tagen frei testen sofern sie 48
stunden lang symptomfrei waren das war
zuvor nicht möglich
also da man jetzt einige punkte dabei
die wir jetzt schön der reihe nach
aufarbeiten wollen mit professor lehr
wir arbeiten daran dass wir gleich auch
noch mit herrn schiffe sprechen können
das dauert noch einen kleinen moment
aber jetzt können wir das ja auch gut
nutzen um schon mal ein bisschen über
das medizinisch fachlicher zu sprechen
gehen wir mal das ganze der reihe nach
durch also die gastronomie wurde
angesprochen ab mitte januar 2 g + aus
ihrer sicht doch wahrscheinlich auch
eine sinnvolle maßnahme ja definitiv
eine sinnvolle maßnahme weil wir hier
ein paar normalen verschärfung erreichen
die absolut notwendig ist vor allem beim
trinken ist es ja unmöglich die maske
auch zu behalten das heißt da sind wir
relativ lange im geschützten raum und da
ist es wichtig wirklich die maximale
sicherheit wirklich zu gewährleisten ob
das ausreichend wird das werden wir
sehen wir können es halt nur hoffen aber
sicherlich der richtige schritt
nächster wichtiger punkt ist die
quarantäne regelung gepostete menschen
frisch geimpfte aber vor allem eben auch
die gewusst hatten müssen gar nicht in
quarantäne wenn sie kontaktpersonen sind
das ist eine neue vorgehensweise bislang
teilte das also galt das zumindest bei
kontakt mit omikron
personen um ikon infizierten personen 14
tage also das ist schon eine ziemliche
kehrtwende und die sorgt zumindest jetzt
auch bei unseren zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer nicht immer nur für
verständnis da schreibt zum beispiel
martina huber über facebook na toll
gemusterte müssen nicht in quarantäne da
freut sich das großraumbüro diese
entscheidung ist mehr als fahrlässig
genau deswegen werden wir noch mehr
infizierte haben wie ist da die
einschätzung des fachmanns
ja also sicherlich ist es so dass die
geposteten deutlich geringere
übertragungsfähigkeit und auch ein
geringeres
infektionsschutz glaube ich ist das hier
vor allem eine politische entscheidung
die er getroffen wurde also er ist
einfach nicht in der rot nutzen risiko
abwägung gemacht worden dass man gesagt
hat wenn wir sehr hohe fallzahlen
bekommen werden selbst mit mildem
verlauf wären wir sehr viele erkrankte
haben und das wird natürlich auch eine
menge kontaktperson mit sich ziehen und
wenn wir die alle auch noch in
quarantäne schicken dann werden wir mehr
oder weniger ja geisterstädte und ein
geister land vorfinden was wir natürlich
nicht wollen das heißt also damit die
infrastruktur aufrechterhalten wird egal
ob kritisch oder nicht ist sicherlich
nötig diese quarantäne zu verkürzen und
vor allem auf die quarantäne eigentlich
von den kontaktpersonen ich glaube aber
schon dass hier die eigenverantwortung
letztendlich gelten sollte auch von
denjenigen die dann kontakt waren das
heißt also weiter auf symptome achten
ich glaube das wird ganz wichtig sein
aber letztendlich sind wir hier im
moment haben bei der omicron variante in
der situation dass wir einfach nicht
mehr diese hundertprozentige sicherheit
wirklich haben können wir müssen jetzt
ja ein gewisses risiko eingehen damit
das land aufrecht erhalten bleiben kann
in seiner infrastruktur besonders
glücklich bin ich damit nicht aber ich
sehe die politische wendigkeit also eine
politische entscheidung letztlich auch
eine abwägung eberhard schlecker über
facebook fragt auch ganz interessante
dem zusammenhang wenn die symptome bei
allen virusvarianten gleich sind der
test gleich ist wir werden dann diese
verschiedenen virus varianten
unterschieden woher weiß ich dann womit
genau ich infiziert worden bin
na ja letztendlich brauchen sie dafür
dann eigentlich ja sequenzierung ist es
das ist damit wohl seine besten
hinbekommen da schneidet man dann
letztendlich das genom das ja das virus
klein und dann können sie entscheiden
dann an der mutationen welche mutter
eigentlich vorgelegen hat aber ich gehe
davon aus dass diese frage spätestens in
zwei drei wochen völlig überflüssig sein
wird weil wir dann alle omikron haben
werden genauso wie im moment vielleicht
der großteil oder vielleicht die hälfte
ungefähr noch delta hat aber bis vor
kurzem hatten wir alle der älter da
konnte man sich relativ sicher sein ich
gehe davon aus dass dann auch nicht mehr
bei jedem sequenziert werden wird
dankeschön bis hierhin ich lese einfach
gerade noch mal ein paar kommentare vor
ganz wertfrei michael wiechert schreibt
uns über facebook wer alle paar wochen
die regeln ändert zeigt damit nur dass
er nichts im griff hat und nicht mal ein
paar wochen im voraus plant wie gesagt
ich enthalte mich jetzt mal der
kommentierung florian mader über youtube
und was hatten die alle noch vor der
wahl versprochen die impfpflicht wird
noch die gerichte beschäftigen da kommen
wir vielleicht gleich noch zur pflicht
und karin kapers über youtube also kommt
keine allgemeine impfpflicht sei es wohl
verstanden obwohl es sich der großteil
der bevölkerung gewünscht hat ja bevor
wir über die impfpflicht sprechen lassen
so dass vielleicht gerade noch heller
sprechen über die situation bei den
schülern die sollen sich nach fünf tagen
frei testen können ganz allgemein wie
bewerten sie die situation an den
schulen
ja also ich denke erst mal diese frei
testen die kann ich schon nachvollziehen
weil die schülerinnen und schüler sind
wirklich die gruppe die sich wirklich
permanent und konstant testet und da
auch ein großes lob und dankeschön an
die schülerinnen und schüler dass sie
das tun und wirklich diese ganzen mühsal
auf sich nehmen was in anderen betrieben
und woanders nicht so einfach möglich
ist funktioniert dort gut und das ist
sehr gut trotzdem muss ich natürlich
sagen dass ich immer wieder auch
enttäuschend finde wie wenig eigentlich
auch die schülerinnen und schüler
eingegangen wir haben jetzt nur die
verkürzte quarantänezeit und die freie
testmöglichkeit eigentlich gesehen aber
nichtsdestotrotz brauchen wir eigentlich
vor allem für die schulen konzepte wir
lassen die jetzt in einer wand rein
rennen mit massiven infektionszahlen
dort haben wir letztendlich den teil der
schülerinnen und schüler der bevölkerung
die am wenigsten geimpft sind auch wenn
er sie es vielleicht schon könnten sind
sie es noch nicht das ist aber nicht
immer nur ihre alleinige entscheidung
also von daher glaube ich dass wir hier
in meinen augen auch ein gewisses risiko
eingehen was langzeitfolgen an geht über
longo wird möchte er sowieso niemand
mehr reden aber wir müssen das trotzdem
bei kindern auch mal wieder auf das
tablett bringen das ist eine wichtige
erkrankung die auftritt und wenn wir
hier wirklich millionenfach schülerinnen
und schüler infizieren glaube ich wenn
wir auch lange zeit noch daran haben und
uns ja sehr unangenehm daran erinnern
was wir eigentlich getan haben also mir
fehlt wirklich der schutz es gibt eine
schöne s3-leitlinie die eigentlich noch
nicht ausreichend umgesetzt wird wir
sind also wirklich weitere maßnahmen
nötig und man sollte glaube ich für den
peak auch mal überlegen ob die
präsenzpflicht wirklich nicht auch mal
ausgesetzt werden kann ich denke niemand
würde jetzt wirklich auch bei einem
heranziehe orkan ist würde man wirklich
sagen da muss man auch 1000 spielen weil
so gesund ist ich glaube es gibt phasen
in denen man sich auch mal zurückziehen
kann und ich denke jetzt werden die
quelle dann vielleicht in den nächsten
wochen über uns rollt das wir hier ganz
dringend darüber nachdenken müssen ob
die präsenzpflicht wirklich notwendig
ist weil sie gerade das thema longo wird
auch bei schülern angesprochen haben
welche erkenntnisse haben sie dazu
ja ich sage mal da sind die studien
natürlich sehr diffus muss man sagen es
gibt aber schon viele auch gesicherte
studieren die zeigen dass letztendlich
auch bis zu jedem zehnten kind so bzw
schülerinnen schüler also unter
18-jährigen auch anlagen kugel zum
thematischen leiden die sind definitiv
und nachgewiesen aber wie gesagt die
geiste streiten sich ein bisschen über
die häufigkeit letztendlich ist es auch
fast egal wie häufig es ist wichtig ist
dass es auftritt und zwar relativ häufig
und ich glaube darf dementsprechend
müssen wir wirklich sorge tragen weil
wovor ich mir eigentlich sorgen macht
und wirklich die langzeitfolgen durch
das virus und nicht eine langzeitfolge
durch eine impfung und wie gesagt das
ist die gruppe die noch am
allerwenigsten geimpftes wir sehen jetzt
mit nikon eben auch vermehrt die kinder
die kleinen kinder die ins krankenhaus
gehen da gibt es auch wieder sehr
widersprüchliche aussagen aber wir haben
das beispielsweise bei der influenza
auch dort haben sie die junge population
die relativ häufig im krankenhaus dann
auftritt also bei der normalen grippe
haben sie auch ein viertel der grippe
infizierten dem krankenhaus sind unter
18 und ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass
es hierbei omikron aus so ist weil wir
hier anscheinend ja auch eine gewisse 7
juni scale kann das heißt also wer noch
immer diese kinder möglicherweise vorher
eine immunität hatten durch
kreuzreaktionen ständig auch hier
irgendwie außer kraft gesetzt zu sein
von daher sind vor allem auch die
kleinen die unter fünfjährigen wie wir
noch nicht geimpft und noch einen großen
risiko ausgesetzt also wie gesagt aus
meiner sicht ist das relativ fahrlässig
was da gerade gehandelt
soviel zum thema schule florian ennahda
fragt uns über youtube durchgeimpft und
gemustert und 2g plus für die
gastronomie aber zum einkauf darf man wo
ist da die logik ich nehme an das hängt
auch mit einer abwägung zusammen und der
tatsache dass man eben den leuten nicht
verbieten und möchte zum einkaufen zu
gehen weil das ja ein grundbedürfnis
sozusagen ist ja richtig das ist
natürlich die grundversorgung muss
weiter gesichert sein und letztendlich
glaube ich die personen müssen dann
letztendlich einkaufen gehen das ist ein
grundrecht das sie haben das man aber
letztendlich halt in der gastronomie
einschränken kann trotzdem ist natürlich
der gastronomie auch noch mal dafür
bringen sie längere zeit in einem
geschlossenen raum an einem tisch
vielleicht doch mit nachbarn und da ist
das risiko deutlich größer als wenn im
supermarkt mit masken jemanden vorbei
schlendern sie haben ja auch die
möglichkeit geben durch maske und auch
durch desinfizieren sich selber zu
schützen noch den einkaufswagen zu
desinfizieren also man kann ja selber
auch das risiko minimieren das ist eben
im restaurant durch das abnehmen der
markt relativ schwierig weil sie dann
halt ja durch die aufnahme von speis und
trank letztendlich dazu gezwungen sind
auch die maske wegzunehmen und wenn
neben ihnen jemand unter aero sohle
verbreitet und die lüftung nicht gut
genug ist dann haben sie natürlich
selber das problem da sind wir mitten
beim thema und freuen uns dass wir die
runde jetzt doch erweitern können um
olaf schritte von haben wir ihn schon
kurz gesehen den präsidenten des
deutschen hotel und gaststättenverbandes
dehoga in brandenburg ich hoffe jetzt
klappt alles auch mit dem ton ich
begrüße sie nochmal recht herzlich wir
haben jetzt die ganze zeit schon über
die heute getroffenen beschlüsse
gesprochen es gab ja im vorfeld auch
gerade von ihrem verband große bedenken
was zweig plus zb betreffend wurde eben
für die einkehr in restaurants oder auch
in hotels wie sehen sie jetzt die
beschlüsse ja erst mal einen schönen
guten abend aus dem schönen land
brandenburg und hier speziell aus dem
spreewald freue mich dass sich an der
diskussion teilnehmen kann natürlich
nicht in allem der meinung von professor
aber möchte vielleicht voranstellen dass
ich so ein bisschen das gefühl habe ewig
grüßt uns dass moment ja also wir sind
jetzt in der vierten welle und jedes mal
kommen dieselben diskussion auf jedes
mal ist die gastronomie und die
hotellerie die erste branche die
irgendwie opfer bringen muss und ich
kann da vielen kollegen glaube ich auch
aus dem herzen zu sprechen
dass die über 220.000 betriebe in
unserer branche da sehr sehr gelitten
haben in den letzten zwei jahren und
viele dass man durch zusagen auch den
kanal voll haben die maßnahmen die jetzt
wieder als insbesondere die gastronomie
treffen
haben für mich so eher den anschein naja
wir müssen mal wieder was tun
bis dato ist in keiner weise
nachgewiesen worden auch in den
vergangenen wellen dass die gastronomie
und hotellerie handel mit treiber waren
ganz im gegenteil das ist die branche
glaube ich mit am meisten investiert hat
in vorsorgemaßnahmen die am meisten
investiert hat dahingehend die menschen
zu schützen auch zu kontrollieren und
auch ein organisiertes freizeitleben in
diesen schwierigen zeiten zu
organisieren
das will ihnen glaube ich keiner
abstreiten dieses bemühen vielleicht
gerade noch mal die nachfrage ist ist
jetzt zweig plus oder
geburtstag sozusagen entschieden worden
macht es für sie keinen unterschied ist
dann nicht sozusagen durch die
möglichkeit der musterung das doch
einfach auch für ihre gäste die dann
kommen könnten für einige wird das schon
einfacher sein natürlich irgendwie fern
die brust und nun sind so viel sich das
dann macht weiß ich nicht da gibt es
natürlich experten die das besser
beurteilen können als ich aber wir
wissen ja auch sehen dass gerade
gastronomie ein thema als
freizeitgestaltung wo ich mit der ganzen
familie hingehen möchte und wenn dann
zwei gebucht sind zwei nicht und müssen
dann noch ins zentrum laufen und und und
also ich glaube viele für viele familien
wird es dann eher so sei die sagen dann
kochen wir doch lieber zu hause bevor
wir uns ja diese ganzen mühen
unterziehen und der großteil der gast
von morgen sieht das auch ganz ganz
kritisch verstehe wir wollen gerade
nochmal hier eine userin mit reinnehmen
gabriele holstein über facebook fragt
uns die auflagen müssen auch die
restaurantbesitzer und das personal
erfüllen da spricht keiner von wir haben
es doch gerade aktuell auf sylt gesehen
dort war das personal infiziert genauso
war es auf den schiffen das überwiegend
das personal infiziert war warum erwähnt
man das nicht ich weiß doch nicht wenn
ich ein restaurant betrete ob das
personal dann auch tatsächlich geimpft
ist können sie ihr diese sorge nehmen
oder wie bewerten sie diese problematik
die sorge kann ich nicht nehmen die
steht ja schon seit monaten im raum dass
die gesetzlichen vorschriften ebenso
sind dass es zum teil so widersinnig ist
dass die mitarbeiter dann vielleicht
nicht getestet werden müssen oder oder
nicht geimpft sein müssten je nach der
lage in den in den einzelnen
bundesländern und die gäste müssen dass
also da gibt es ja auch schon tolle
kommentare also ich muss mich bedienen
lassen dann von leuten die da vielleicht
weniger weniger gesundheits vorsorge
getroffen haben als ich selber ich weiß
aber auch von vielen vielen
kolleginnen die da sehr viel wert darauf
legen dass ihre mitarbeiter gesund und
tatsächlich auch zusätzlich getestet
werden aber hier gibt es glaube ich auch
in der umsetzung in den ländern noch
einige hürden zu überwinden
versteh wir spielen ein bisschen pink
bon ich würde gerne thorsten lehrern
noch mal wieder auch in die runde
einbeziehen eine frage die wir nämlich
an ihn haben von unserer zuschauer in
hanna über youtube muss man dann in den
nachfolgenden jahren davon ausgehen dass
jedes jahr aufs neue eine booster
impfung benötigt wird wie ist ihre
einschätzung dazu wird sich das jetzt
endlos sozusagen im kreis drehen
ja das ist glaube ich eine ziemlich gute
frage die auch noch keiner wirklich
seriös beantworten kann ich glaube viele
arbeiten oder beziehungsweise hoffen
jetzt darauf dass durch das orgon virus
jetzt die lage von pandemien in dem
übergeht das heißt dann hätten wir die
ähnliche situation wie das auch beim
influenza haben oder weil typischen
erkältungskrankheit die frage wird sein
wie stark schwächt sich das ab brauchen
wir dann überhaupt noch eine impfung
oder nicht ich glaube da gibt es
szenarien in alle richtungen glaube
viele hoffen darauf dass es sich ähnlich
entwickelt während bei anderen
coronaviren auch dass wir jetzt eine
abschwächung über die jahre sehen das
könnte sehr zu hoffen seien aber
gesichert ist das nicht ich kann man
sicherlich den optimismus darin sehen
ich denke aber der große vorteil den wir
jetzt mit den impfungen haben es
wirklich dass wir sie entsprechend
anpassen können dass mir glaube ich auch
hier über dem chor virus wieder sehen
werden dass wir eine saisonalität zählen
werden das heißt wir werden wieder
fallende zahlen sehen wenn es richtung
frühling geht und wenn es noch mal eine
welle gibt von ich persönlich fast
ausgehe dann wird sie wieder im
september oktober starten und das heißt
davon müssten wir uns entsprechend
wieder schützen und die impfstoffe
können wir jedem entsprechend anpassen
ja wie gesagt ich befürchte dass dieses
spiel noch ein bisschen weiter gehen
wird so schnell werden wir aus dem
zirkel er nicht aussteigen können aber
ich habe doch eine gewisse hoffnung das
wären 14 jahren dort auch mal wieder in
der normalität übergehen können aber ein
zwei jahre wird es dann schon noch
dauern
ja es gibt wie gesagt keine richtig
seriöse schätzung das ist leider sehr
schwierig weil wir nicht genau wissen
wie dieses virus dich weiterentwickeln
sie dürfen ja nicht vergessen im moment
haben diese wären ja ich sag mal das
sind perfekte castingshow bedingungen
die sie haben das heißt er sich einem
sind sowohl oder fitteste varianten
wären massive infektionen überall die
varianten treffen wunderbar auf eine
ganze menge geimpfte leute die können
theoretisch ja varianten herausfiltern
die auch im juni skater verrufen und
deswegen sich die situation ein bisschen
kritisch und ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass nikon uns noch mal was beehren wird
bis jetzt haben wir das in der munteren
6 monats rhythmus gesehen damit den
südfrankreich schon mal wieder eine
variante gesehen wer weiß was aus der
wird aber auch überall anders entstehen
varianten dadurch dass wir sie nicht
monitoren kriegen wir das ja eh nicht so
richtig mit in deutschland andere länder
machen das nächste besser ich würde
sagen ich glaube bei diesen
infektionszahlen wir weltweit gerade
sehen dürfen uns nicht irre ihren lassen
wenn noch mal was auftritt es hilft auch
nicht wenn wir deutschland dämpfen wir
müssen das letztendlich global machen
und da sehe ich noch überhaupt kein
konzept wir schaffen uns ja die lage im
eigenen land nicht in griff zu kriegen
aber global haben wir natürlich noch
ganz andere probleme und da können uns
noch eine menge zusammen brüten und
braun dass uns dann am morgen die ohren
fliegen kann ja sehr hoffnungsvoll
stimmt das nicht aber okay ich verstehe
natürlich ihren punkt und wir werden
sehen wie sich das jahr 2022 dass er
noch so jung ist dann entwickelt klicks
geo menzer fragt uns über youtube wenn
sich so viele menschen impfen und
postern lassen diese frage könnte
vielleicht auch herrn schippe
interessieren dann wieso müssen
restaurants und disco star an oder
darunter besser gesagt leiden politiker
machen einfach das leben schwer so seine
meinung aber bevor wir dazu herrn
schiffe hören vielleicht gerade doch
noch mal die einschätzung auch des
medizinischen fach man sozusagen bzw
pharmazeutischen fachmanns wie würden
sie das bewerten wir haben ja herrn
schippe führen auch gerade schon gehört
er sagte ja wir machen da doch alles was
menschenmöglich ist hell wie sehen sie
das ich glaube wirklich dass die
gastronomiebetriebe und auch
kulturbetriebe sehr viel machen und
wahrscheinlich auch alles was möglich
ist das problem was weil die haben ist
eine variante die sie einfach den
immunsystem erst mal entzieht und
dementsprechend natürlich dann sich auch
unter den kämpfen und auch den robusten
verbreiten kann wir haben das an
verschiedenen stellen schon gesehen in
dänemark und norwegen teilweise sehr
eindrücklich ähnliche situationen haben
wir in deutschland auch gesehen dass
heißt das macht natürlich von den
geimpften geposteten erstmal keinen halt
und das ist natürlich genau die probleme
die wir haben und in diesen
räumlichkeiten kommen wir natürlich eng
zusammen und ich bin ganz bei ihnen dass
wir hier wirklich sehr viele maßnahmen
schon getroffen haben und das tut mir
auch ganz furchtbar leid für diese
branche aber wie kommen wir natürlich
eng und gesellig zusammen das ist
natürlich auch sie in dieser ganzen
veranstaltungen aber da wird dann
einfach auch kontakt schwierig oder
kontakte distanz einzeln schwierig und
deswegen glaube ich wird uns das so
nicht helfen vielleicht wenn wir eine
mikronährstoff haben wird die situation
immer ein bisschen anders aussehen aber
im moment scheint ja zumindest das buch
dann auch noch nicht ganz ausreichen
dass wir hier nicht infiziert werden
können ja dann fangen wir doch gerade
mal nach bei herrn schulte sie haben ja
jetzt gerade auch noch mal die
ausführungen gehört was geht ihnen dabei
durch den kopf also ich versuche es mit
dem gesunden menschenverstand zu regeln
und glaube wir sind natürlich
gesellschaftliche wesen und auch
gesellige wesen und ganz ohne dass wir
uns treffen oder dass wir kommunizieren
oder auch mal einen schönen abend
miteinander verbringen wird es auch zu
bränden die zeiten so wird es nicht
funktionieren
und ich glaube gerade wir das von oben
bieten noch den geschützten raum als der
sich manchmal bietet so in den privaten
sphären oder so zu zusammenkünften wo
unkontrolliert dann party stattfinden
ich glaube da bieten wir eine gute
alternative um hier teil der lösung zu
sein und nicht das problem und ich
glaube dieses verständnis das muss man
auch mal den kollegen und den
mitarbeitern rüberbringen in der branche
die sich tatsächlich jetzt ein stückchen
wieder in die ecke gestellt werden in
die schmuddelecke gedrängt fühlen wo sie
gar nicht hingehören also das ist ein
muster natürlich auch gucken wenn es
dann zu ernst ist dass wir nicht mehr
herr der lage sind dann darf es
natürlich auch nicht so sein dass wir
früh in überfüllten bussen und bahnen
fahren und da vielleicht noch die die
die busfahrer und die und die bahnfahrer
krank sind ausfallen züge ausfallen und
die menschen dort übereinander sitzen um
von a nach b zu kommen ich glaube diese
diese dinge die müssen mal müssen wir
zugleich auch angehen und nicht nur
sagen die kelten zu machen und damit
können wir vielleicht die pandemie
besiegen ich glaube das ist der falsche
ansatz und ich habe das gefühl wir
stochern hier tatsächlich auch nach zwei
jahren noch zu sehr nebel und ich würde
mir auch wünschen dass wir dass wir
vielleicht noch ein paar mehr experten
auch als auch aus unserer branche und
aus anderen betroffenen branchen dann
auch in solche entscheidungsfindungen
mit dazu nehmen dann wissen die ihnen
die tatsächlich immer dass hinterher aus
dem pkw und dann erfahren was wir zu tun
oder zu lassen haben und sind dann
werden wären dann ich sag mal beruhigte
indem gesagt naja bekommt ja geld dafür
aber wir wollen keine wir wollen keine
bittsteller sein wir wollen nicht am
abend an am kopf dass wir dann zumindest
das kratzen sondern wir wollen
eigentlich das machen was wir am besten
können und das ist gute gastgeber zu
sein
irgendwie zum spielball hier auch der
politik zu werden ja dann würde ich sie
dann ganz konkret noch mal fragen wollen
was ihre erwartungen eigentlich an die
politik derzeit sind sie haben gerade
schon gesagt überbrückt hilfen gut und
schön aber das ist es eigentlich nicht
was würden sie sich konkret wünschen
jetzt wird wieder zunächst wünschen dass
wir dass wir vielleicht eine
gesellschaft auch noch ein bisschen
ehrlicher und ein bisschen breiter
miteinander diskutieren so betonen die
politiker sind sich alle einig und man
hat sollte heute gesehen viel harmonie
wurde verbreitet ich habe auch
mitteilung scholz da schon persönlich
diskutieren dürfen
diese machen das natürlich auch clever
aber trotzdem hat man immer das gefühl
es ist eine einseitig geprägte
geschichte irgendwo ausnahmen öffnet um
heraus
man sollte doch tatsächlich auch uns
damit zu rate ziehen diejenigen die
betroffen sind und wenn darüber da ein
bisschen ehrlicher miteinander hat auch
diskutieren und auch andere meinungen zu
lassen ist so ohne dass ich jetzt auf
die straße gehe und lex und werde gegen
acht werde aber einfach einfach eine
ehrliche diskussion wie wir die wir doch
zu den besten lösungen kommen und ist
nicht nicht nur irgendwo so in hinter
verschlossenen türen und dann jetzt
müsst ihr das alle umsetzen ich würde
mir wünschen dass man mit granaten tisch
rät nochmals mit welche lösungen auch im
gastgewerbe umzusetzen sind damit auch
die sicherheit unserer gäste dann noch
höher sein kann also die gastronomen
fordern mehr einbezogen zu wehren noch
mal ein klares sozusagen plädoyer von
olaf schöpe der präsident des deutschen
hotel und gaststättenverbandes war das
für uns in brandenburg ganz herzlichen
dank dass sie sich heute am zeit
genommen haben um ihre positionen hier
auch nochmal zu erläutern dankeschön
vielen dank und schönen abend danke
gleichfalls und wir sprechen noch ganz
kurz mit herrn leer der hoffentlich noch
in der leitung ist und da würde ich dann
einfach auch gerade noch mal ein oder
zwei user fragen vortragen wollen
becketts fragt uns ab wann wird man bei
uns endlich die kurve medikamente kaufen
können es mag ja noch immer menschen
geben die tabletten für sicherer halten
als impfungen warum auch immer frage ich
mich jetzt aber okay wie ist ihre
einschätzung dazu verwandelt es
medikamente geben naja die ersten sind
ja quasi auf dem auf dem weg zur
zulassung bzw die apotheken also das
wird jetzt im januar geschehen das ist
erst mal sehr gut das wird auch auf
jeden fall helfen das muss man sich
sicher sein aber die substanzen wie
paket müssen halt auch beispielsweise
rechtzeitig eingesetzt werden das wird
wichtig sein aber trotzdem sind sie da
aber ja wir haben es schon eigentlich
gerade gehört in dem kommentar so ein
bisschen ironisch wer sich letztendlich
nicht impfen lässt muss man mal schauen
ob jetzt nicht diese leute dann auch
wirklich diese medikamente einnehmen ich
denke es ist sehr gut vor allem für
leute die ein potenziell schweren
verlauf haben immunsupprimierten sind
das auch wirklich nehmen wollen sind das
wunderbare medikamente aber wir dürfen
auch nicht vergessen die haben eine
menge wechselwirkungen wer sich bei
medikamenten vielleicht bei der impfung
sorgen macht dass ein wenig leuten
getestet wurde die wurden auch noch
nicht an so viel getestet weshalb ich
auf keinen fall schlecht man will aber
ich würde sagen auch hier sind wir jetzt
ganz am anfang da müssen wir noch viel
lernen aber ich denke wir werden jetzt
im januar damit da mit der
markteinführung rechnen das ist jetzt ja
alles bestellt auf dem weg und wird in
kürze verfügbar sein das ist doch
wiederum eine gute nachricht rum über
youtube fragt uns wird der neue
impfstoff im april wenn er denn dann
kommt gegen omikron auch die alten
varianten abdecken
ja dazu ist ehrlich gesagt meines
wissens noch nicht bekannt aber da habe
ich die frage habe ich auch noch nicht
versucht zu erörtern ich gehe ehrlich
gesagt davon aus dass auch die in einer
gewissen weise erkannt werden das kommt
aber sehr stark darauf an wie die firmen
biotech oder moderner den letztendlich
design haben ich hoffe ehrlich gesagt
dass ich ein breites spektrum abgedeckt
haben ich gehe davon aus aber ich kann
es im moment leider noch nicht sagen tja
das würde ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch
wünschen dass die aber darum geht es ja
nicht was wir uns wünschen
eine frage noch von estoril über youtube
haben wir denn den peak bei den
todeszahlen erreicht das ist natürlich
auch ein bisschen der blick in die
glaskugel aber was halten sie für
wahrscheinlich wie sind wir da unterwegs
was dieses doch sehr bedrückendes thema
angeht ja es ist natürlich schwierig
glaube ich wir haben im moment in
deutschland einfach nur eine relativ
große impflücken bei den über
60-jährigen und das handy natürlich die
sehr schweren verlauf haben können das
alter spielt eine ganz große rolle und
haben wir sehr viele immer noch nicht
gehen mit dem vergleich zu anderen das
heißt sie befürchtet auch hier dass wir
hier noch eine gewisse steigerung der
todeszahlen sehen können ich glaube
nicht dass es so heftig sein wird wie im
letzten winter wo wir teilweise mehr als
1000 tote pro tag haben aber wir haben
ja auch in der letzten zeit gesehen
jetzt trotzdem mit dem delta virus das
nach über 500 leute am tag gestorben
sind gefühlt hat es niemanden
interessiert ich glaube die todeszahlen
sind auch gefühlt nicht mehr so
interessant aber es ist sehr tragisch
was sich dort abspielt ich glaube auch
das lässt sich nicht seriös sagen weil
wir wissen nicht welche varianten
vielleicht noch kommen wir wissen nicht
wie lange letztendlich diese pandemie
noch gehen wird aber ich hoffe es
natürlich sehr wir sind sicherlich mit
den neuen medikamenten und impfstoffen
in angepassten impfstoffen an der
brüstung auf einem guten weg aber
auch hier seriöse aussagen sind wirklich
sehr schwierig letzte frage von mir
frage ich immer gerne wenn ich mit so
einem kompetenten fachmann mit ihnen
spreche dann geht es finde ich auch mal
ein bisschen darum nochmal abzufragen
was die sozusagen vorschläge sind die
kapelle die vielleicht eben auch leute
wie sie haben an uns an die bevölkerung
wie wir uns auch jetzt im neuen jahr
verhalten sollten um da eben möglichst
gut durchzukommen was sind sozusagen die
wichtigsten verhaltenstipps die wir 2022
auch befolgen sollten ja ich glaube als
erstes müssen wir uns wieder in unsere
sage ich mal grund maßnahmen erinnern
die wir alle mal schön eingehalten haben
also a half cell plus corona bahn app
das sind die wichtigen kriterien die wir
weiterhin brauchen wir haben ein
bisschen ignoriert ich glaube die
geimpften und gemusterten fühlen sich
sehr sicher dass das muss man jetzt
wieder zurückzudrehen wir jetzt ein
bisschen wie bei monopoly gehen sie
zurück auf los ziehen sie keine 1000
euro 1 oder wie das ging aber
letztendlich ist es wieder ein bisschen
zurück auf null was wir haben das heißt
wir müssen hier wirklich schauen dass
jetzt auch die letztendlich die
geimpften und gemusterten sich
infizieren können das sollten wir
möglichst verhindern das gilt jetzt
immer zu verhindern wir werden es
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz verhindern ich
glaube das ist wichtig ist bleibt aber
auch ganz wichtig dass wir uns impfen
und postern lassen wenn vorhin von herrn
scholz schon gehört auch die erste
impfung schützt schon
aber je mehr impfungen sie haben umso
besser das heißt also natürlich in den
mit den entsprechenden abständen hoch
bis hoch sich zitieren auf die dritte
impfung wird wichtig sein und ja
letztendlich glaube ich müssen wir
gesellschaftlich versuchen das zusammen
durchzustehen das wird ein bisschen
unangenehm noch werden aber ich habe
schon hoffnung dass es eben mit dem
eintreffen letztendlich der ersten
sonnenstrahlen und des frühlings dass es
im april auch wieder deutlich sinkende
fallzahlen geben wird weil da hilft uns
die saisonalität wieder aber ich glaube
wichtig ist vielleicht ein punkt noch
dass die dass die politik eigentlich
auch mal offen kommuniziert was
eigentlich das ziel in dieser pandemie
ist ich denke das sind dinge die der
bevölkerung nicht kommuniziert wird weil
es gibt ja zwei strategien die
eigentlich gefahren werden können das
eine ist ein maximaler schutz von
bevölkerung und langzeitschäden dann
müsste man letztendlich die fallzahlen
deutlich minimieren oder sowie ist
eigentlich jetzt gehandhabt wird dass
wir eigentlich versuchen das
gesundheitssystem soweit auszutarieren
dass die maximale freiheit haben und ich
glaube das muss einfach mal gesagt
werden weil dann nur dann kann man nicht
verstehen welche maßnahmen hier wirklich
ergriffen werden und ich glaube ohne
diese klare kommunikation an die
bevölkerung ist es sehr schwierig das zu
verstehen deswegen soll die bevölkerung
erst mal nicht resignieren und das
versuchen weiter zu hinterfragen und die
arbeiter tapfer zu bleiben großteil
bevölkerung schlägt sich bisher sehr gut
und dafür auch noch mein herzliches
dankeschön er hat ihn können wir uns nur
anschließen dafür ein herzliches
dankeschön es gebe noch viele punkte zu
besprechen aber wir sind schon deutlich
über der zeit ganz herzlichen dank
torsten leer dass sie sich die zeit für
uns heute genommen haben und uns an
ihren erkenntnissen teilhaben lassen
dankeschön dafür einen schönen abend
schönes wochenende und das gleiche gilt
natürlich auch an unsere userinnen und
user vielen dank für eure zahlreichen
fragen mal wieder und auch die
kommentare wir wissen es ist auch immer
ein emotionales thema manche kommentare
war nicht so dass man sie gut vorlesen
konnte wir bitten euch in zukunft da
natürlich darauf zu achten dass das so
ist dass wir das hier auch vortragen
können dann erhöht sich auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ihr gehört werde
trotzdem dafür und alles gute bleibt
gesund bis demnächst